we've done one already I think called it
mentioning the Toolman break and it's
got to the stage now where somebody
comes and says remind us what was the
tilt Minh break why was it so important
and so on the Tilghman break exploited a
weakness in any cipher that's based on
bitwise exclusive or as indeed all the
Tunney traffic exactly was just that I
suppose I could very briefly and not
using too much notation to frighten
computer scientists but just just
reminder what happens with exclusive or
which I'll denote with a plus in a
circle and effectively what happens with
it is that if you take a piece of
plaintext and you add on to it a key
character what you'll end up with is an
insightful version of that playing
character and it's all done with bitwise
exclusive or and if you say well in what
code are these characters expressed then
in what we're talking about in the
middle 1940s it was the International
teleprinter code five-hole which have
been well known for quite a few years
since the twenties I think and it was
used for telegrams telex transatlantic
communications and so on so what happens
then is if you take something and
exclusive or it was something else a
five whole trade character you will get
encrypted text if you look at that and
then visit the zig zag decryption video
where Sean and I've done of even a
simpler example you'll find out how
zigzag decryption works you get a bit of
plain text one it produces plain text to
the plaintext two goes on a little bit
further and then that predicts a bit
more of plaintext one and you flip flop
between the two streams that's why it's
called zig zag decryption
so using zig zag decryption on all of
three thousand characters very early on
in this game
the Allies really had got an absolute
bonanza here because if you then go back
and say well look we know the plain text
now we know what ciphertext we received
exclusive or tells us that plaintext +
cipher text gives key we've got three
thousand characters worth of key so why
was he call the children break well it
was called a Tilghman break because
Colonel John Tillman who was a
mathematician as well as being a
military man knew about the properties
and the weaknesses of exclusive-or and
he knew that under addition like this
the key would cancel out and you and you
could use this as exactly he did it it
took him ten days and he's a German
expert as well
you had enough mathematics knowledge but
was a serious military German expert we
do make it painfully easy and we do wave
our hands and greatly oversimplify it
you've got to remember this in real life
what happens issues things agging and
then suddenly your German expert says oh
dear I can't see that that's the start
of a new German word old dear and in the
end you might get blocked but not often
because what you can then do is look
further along the message and see if you
can guess another island in the middle
it might be geheime that was another
good word secret why not drag geheime
through the D string with exclusive-or
and see if you get something looking
like geheime at the same place below
it's in the other one so you got islands
of decrypted stuff and your job was to
link the islands and get everything
including the less common German words
that had appeared and in the end tilman
did it ten days it took him I think it
would to train him a lot less if he had
to do it the second time obviously
because she get the hang of the zigzag
technique so tilman has done all this
work but it i think for a month or two
in the research section nobody could
figure out what on earth sort of machine
it was that could be generating stuff
that look like this so new recruit built
her from cambridge and rolled for
chemistry degree not mathematics but
very keen on
recreational mathematics it was given
the job and he decided that having loads
at cypher school that if you think that
there could be a periodicity in the
cipher then you better start looking for
what period what repetition or age it
was on and prior to being put to work on
this Tillman break he'd worked on a
similar cogs based ciphering machine a
Swedish one called the haggling machine
and I think it's fair to say that
there's enough similarity there that is
all yeah maybe it's a cogs machine prime
numbers of cogs because we've discovered
the prime or relative prime of the
numbers of cogs is the magic formula and
he said ok the head of the section Jerry
Morgan has told me that they have reason
to believe that one of the cogs in this
machine has got 23 teeth on it so we've
covered in another video how we started
looking for 23 but accidentally found 41
however there is something following on
after that which is intended to
randomize it sufficiently well as it
will disguise the 41 but it's not being
done well enough and occasionally the 41
SOT of this is breaking through the murk
and convinces that that's right
so he announces this to the rest of the
research section and they go mad for
several weeks trying to find out what
the other streams must be because don't
forget it's teleprinter code five
streams 1 2 3 4 5 but looks like some
kind of two-stage mechanism there's an
initial attempt to encroach this but
then there's a follow-up that's trying
to disguise the periodicity of all these
wheels well after a lot of effort by all
the research section they cracked it so
here is what happens you feed in an
order e teleprinter character into this
adaptor it goes through the first set of
wheels which built up in all the things
I read nobody explains why he decided he
would call the first
will the Chi Will's the Greek character
Chi which is written out like that and
the second set that follows on
afterwards there they are look here's
the first set that is then passed on
into a second set of wheels which he
called the Sai wheels and there's a
character saw those Sai wheels were
meant to give an extra element of
disguise as to exactly what it was the
Chi wheels were doing and to make
decription that bit harder Chi wheels
put out a certain pattern of ones and
zeroes which gets exclusive order of the
incoming character they then all turn on
all the tiles always move in synchrony
together but that doesn't get boring
because there's different number of
teeth on these wheels I mean here on
stream one there's the famous 41 next
wheel along has got 31 teeth then 29 26
not prime but relatively prime to all
the rest 23 that first stage encryption
then travels onto the path I wheels but
the designers the Machine thought it
will make it even harder for the Allies
if we make it so that the sails don't
always move on with every character
let's put in a stutter mechanism or at
least that's what the decrypt is came to
call it sometimes they move in sometimes
they don't
okay that will make it harder actually
in the end it made it easier as several
statisticians pointed out but that was
the way it was and the reason that bill
Turk was able to prevail and to see 41
was that the purse I wheel patterns were
really bad and by really bad I mean they
left the second set of wheels not
rotating four five six seven characters
on end you know they didn't change the
pattern at all so you've got this great
thing where very clearly it was been
exclusive Ward in the second stage with
the same thing over and over and over
again and if that gets up to six or
seven times it's basically saying it's
only a single stage machine again
because the
is varying fast enough built up said he
said thank heavens for this we were so
lucky in the war number one the tilt
Minh break that trap should not have
sent that message again and given us
three thousand two hundred characters of
key potentially but what really finished
them was that they failed to disguise
the periodicity of the Chi wheels
because they had inadequate sigh wheel
pans that great long unaltered stretches
come through and that's what gave us
just enough evidence that we could work
out that the sign wheels had got 43 47
51 53 59 and so on so we won't go into
the details of precisely how that
calamity occurred let's just say that
whoever was in charge of side wheel
movements really goofed in the early
stages and as tested again says it
didn't matter that when we came back
later they put their error right and
made it better in future by that time we
knew the periodicity of the wheels so
the only worry then was and another of
bill touch some colleagues and later his
PhD supervisor actually a guy called
Sean Wiley who was down the hill in hut
8 with Alan Turing and various other
wirless was brought up the hill along
with Jack good and Donald Michie people
were brought from hut 8 and naval enigma
to help out with tummy and Sean Wiley in
one of his writings about this says do
you know the thing that panicked us
straight after finding out this
wonderful layout of the machine let's
hope these wheels were not
interchangeable could you imagine if
it's instead of having 4131 so on down
here it was possible to pick them out
and put them in different slots and
permute I'm like on enigma and he said
thank heavens after analyzing several
weeks of traffic we were convinced these
things were fixed it was always going to
be 4131 whatever so that's one big worry
out of the way so that was more or less
the situation that was left then you've
got this fabulous break
the keys subtracted itself out there was
enough indications in there to work out
what the periodicity of the wheels was
and they're all relatively prime to each
other but where do we go from here
whenever somebody uses the correct
initial and the same initial setting
which they shouldn't do their order not
to do it if ever this happens again and
gives what Bletchley Park calls the
depth and you remember the famous
absolutely famous indicator setting this
is of the tilma brake was H quid Peck cz
mug 12 characters yeah well that was how
they knew it was worthwhile exclusive
oaring them because the operator the
next time round when he repeated it sent
out this thing saying my my settings are
HQ I be PE X YZ n mu G so you know it's
worthwhile exclusive o-ring them
together seeing what you can find out so
they relied absolutely on the factors in
the early days and up until mid to late
1942 the operators were told to send out
the indicator so the other end knew how
to set the wheels relative to one
another
what they didn't do except very
infrequently thank heavens was to change
what's called the pattern on the wheels
it's probably about time we said a
little bit more about that what I've
drawn out for you here on that diagram
is the simplest wheel of all with the
fewest teeth that was 23 here is my
notional starting point and you can see
I've numbered them not one not two not
three not four so just imagine that's
after every exclusive all character that
contributes this wheel is moving
clockwise around from 6 to 7 and then it
moves the position 8 and so on the dot
means this is contributing or 1 when it
comes around to the start position and
otherwise it contributes a 0 so these
things the the dots are called the
patterns on the wheels
now again huge stroke of luck
for the allies it was such a pain
setting up all of these whales all 12 of
them with different patterns and you had
a little slider to slide and ratchet up
and down as well as one is there that
the Germans only changed the patterns
every month true that meant that you had
one month to try and get depths
you know things where the person had
used the same indicator twice it may not
be a writ as a repeat of the same
exactly same message that really was an
absolute gift from on high
typically though an operator I've used H
squid pecks easy mo you know that one
was about parachute dispositions
ensalada curls another one here I've got
to send which is about when general Katz
ins in the next houses is a leaf break
Oh what indication is that oh well let's
use this one again they'll never decrypt
this it doesn't matter so very often
your zigzag was not between two similar
messages it was between two very
different messages but at least they'd
use the same settings but again explain
why you needed German experts around to
say hello you know yes that is the start
of something or other down here so that
was the name of the game hope that the
lazy operators give you depths by using
the same indicators then bill Turk came
up with an extra method in late 41 I
think I said I know let's try and look
for near depths because a slightly less
lazy operator would say H quid pecks
easy mug we're not here and going to use
the same one twice
I'll only change one of them is such a
faff let me just change one of them now
if only one of those settings was
changed and if it happened to be on a
first stage car wheel built up pointed
out that from the other four that you
were new the same as the last time and
only one is change you can with some
mind-bending
attention to complexity and the help of
German experts sitting next to you say
it's not Zima at the end it's our mug so
have we got any other messages from
earlier on that we part broken which had
are in that position who knows that
might help
so he said typically you might end up
with twenty or thirty possibilities one
should propagated this are not said
through all the morass of stuff that
you've got and he said but yeah with the
help of some really good German guys
that could work and that was more
evidence you see because that could be
backtracked into working out what the
wheel patterns were a bit more so I
think the feeling in the research
section was this is okay so long as they
keep sending out the indicator settings
but we need a lot more techniques to get
us out of trouble if that isn't the case
well everybody knows of course that
Turing did everything at Bletchley Park
nobody else was of any importance at all
and I hope that one of the things that
this set of videos may be doing for you
is to emphasize that it very important
though he was he didn't do absolutely
everything one of the problems with the
secrecy particularly in the late
seventies and early eighties when this
new is about Bletchley Park began to
trickle out but a lot was still under
the Official Secrets Act is that some
computer scientists historians and
writers Varian cautiously started saying
oh well if if Turing took what the poles
did for enigma and develop these on and
then did naval enigma and got that
sorted out he's such a genius it stands
to reason it must have been him running
the whole tiny Lawrence Colossus show no
not true I think our friend and
colleague Jack Copeland I was booked you
see up there Colossus would be the first
to want me to say no Alan Turing did had
nothing to do with Colossus Colossus was
purely Tommy flowers he did make a
contribution towards the decrypting Tony
F
and it was a very very helpful one here
we are in early 42 there's been the
Toolman break built art has worked back
from that and the research section
helped him to find out the disposition
of the wheels on this Toni ciphering
machine what was the problem because
every message sent out on that machine
had an indicator showing the start
positions of all of the cogwheels the
bigger problem was the worry that the
patterns on the wheels the patterns of
zeros and ones a lot of people spent a
lot of brainpower working back through
debts where people had used the same you
know indicator twice trying to backtrack
through the key text into saying what
does this mean about what the patterns
are and in the end if you gathered
enough evidence and certainly with the
Tilton brake there was so much evidence
there they really did get the whole
thing sorted out they managed to work
out for that month exactly what all the
wheel patterns must have been took a lot
of people a lot of effort by hand but it
was done but the worry was we're gonna
more and more be saying we want to get
the patterns at the moment we're saved
by the fact that we have a month to
build up and analyze evidence before it
changes again so you know let's say for
a typical example start of August you
start collecting evidence as to what
this month's patterns must be you look
for debts you've got all the indicators
and by maybe August the 20th or
mid-august if you're very lucky
you've got enough evidence to work out
what the patterns on the wheels are for
this month then you go back to all the
stuff that was transmitted earlier in
the month that you didn't understand but
now you've got the patterns you can go
back and see what the messages were and
so long as the developments in the war
and not happening at a breakneck pace
then the fact that this intelligence was
two weeks old didn't matter too much
because it was high quality intelligence
remember this is Hitler's high command
talking about strategic things so it was
still valuable suddenly I think it was
very 42 the moment they'd all dreaded
calamity somebody in the German High
Command said although it's inconceivable
that this is being broken we are idiots
if we start sending out stuff we don't
need to send out these indicator
settings why not distribute a codebook
to everybody and say I'm using wheel
patents three five six today that's
exactly what they did on enigma remember
same argument came out oh they would
they don't understand it it'll work
it'll be all right no no one step you
know belt and braces approach to this
and don't send information that you
don't need to so there they were then
all of a sudden they didn't know what
the indicator was anymore but they did
know when things were being sent in
depth because a lazy operator would say
to his opposite number I'm using entry
number three five six in the codebook
and then a little later on I'm still
using three five six so you didn't know
what three five six was but you knew it
was a depth with the same start point so
the business about exclusive or addition
and being able maybe to do a bit of
zigzagging still applied but it was a
pain not knowing the settings so this
was the time then by this stage max
Newman who's one of Turing's tutors
remember Cambridge had joined the
research section and his brief that he
set for himself was to mechanize
wherever possible
just like they done for enigma built
hurt came to him very shyly he says one
morning and he was sitting with the
other head of section Jerry Morgan I
think so max Newman was in charge of
mechanization of any food sort and he
formed a subset called the Newman rate
out of Association and then there needed
another much more linguistic space
section run by a chap called major ralph
testa and that of course became the
tester II so the tester II had a few
mathematicians and a lot of linguists
the Newman rear had people who were
really concerned with how do we get
machines to be able to help us with this
any new technique any variants on the
technique was gonna be very helpful so
Alan Turing in early 1942 although he
wasn't part of the research section then
was down in hut 8 doing naval enigma and
we're getting to be very successful
eventually so he said okay I'm going to
take a six week sabbatical with the
research section see what I can bring to
the party he did contribute venturing to
things which were of enormous strategic
help actually the first and in the end
less useful one was that he said what
I'd like to do is to have a rock-solid
method that so long as you've got lots
of depths which we tend to get every
month that you can buy dead reckoning
work out and we could train people to
work out what the patterns were it was
one that he could get to work again you
need an expert German speakers with you
and built her said you know it was
wonderful but I could never get it to
work it was it was branching explosion
of possibilities and when I said to
chirring well which one of those deals
with duty oh you take the one that you
know in your bones is the right one and
and turn said my bones were never good
enough I could never get his method to
work but he could and his collaborators
the idea essentially was that every
wheel has got a different repeat cycle
so what you're saying is let's presume
that at the start position that tooth
and the one next one let's presume they
were zero and one they were contributing
then let's say that on the next wheel
along and each start position it was
zero or one so you can see the binary
explosion beginning to take place but
then let's go back and say no no that
one was one one and that one was zero
one and then work out what happens 23
rotations later on the number five wheel
or 41 rotations
later on the number one wheel you see
it's all perfectly straightforward you'd
have to be aware of the possibilities of
they were both the same while they were
both different on different periodicity
for different wheels and you combine it
all together and everybody's sort of
putting cold compresses on their head
but eventually if you're really
persistent in your brain works that way
they did actually succeed but you had to
have enough depths that you knew what
the key was but also I think what came
from children and Jaco planners book
assures me that it was Turing was the
general observation in all of this work
with the Tunney traffic that it was a
good idea not just to consider the
characters themselves of plaintext or
ciphertext but how about exclusive or
ring them with the one ahead now just
imagine a stream of five whole
characters like this coming down so you
know it was H a P P Y now that's your
paper tape do another one exactly the
same alongside but this time just slip
it back by one what would the net effect
of that be you are exclusive boring
every five bit letter with the one ahead
of it to see what happens why would you
do that
Arthur churring because it will make all
of these doubled letter occurrences
stand out like a sore thumb we have
referred to these in a previous video
how did they ever get into this traffic
and the answer was its language
structure and the nature of exclusive or
if you have happy but you slide the
second P up against the first one on a
separate tape and exclusive all them
anything exclusive orders itself gives
you five dots five dots is a very
unlikely thing to occur by chance but if
you do the Delta technique as it was
called it doesn't matter what repeats
itself it could be double P could be
double Zed it could be because I gather
them
Germantown router operators like my dad
were taught to put in a double space
after every full stop so a lot of the
traffic on Tunney
was double spaces and those count as
well so can you see that by Delta ring
as it was called you are producing a
cascade of zeros just because of the way
exclusive all works and that message was
not lost on Bill touch he said look the
Germans are upping their game all the
time they're really scuppered us for the
moment by not sending the indicator got
to be able to work out what the relative
settings of these wheels were even
without the indicator being given how do
we do that
and he went in to see max Newman the
head of his section at that time and
said I've got this bright idea this
could work and I think Newman and Jerry
Morgan said well yeah but do you need a
depth verbal you know don't know this
would work on anything so long as it's
sufficiently long message full of
ciphertext I can use the Delta method
and statistics to work out what relative
positioning must have been of shall we
say the first two wheels looking left to
right and well how are you gonna do that
well you rely on the fact that when you
Delta things together on a per character
level you produce far more than probable
numbers of five dots which is where two
things that are identical have been
exclusive all together so on every
single stream you're looking at there
will be more dots than crosses for ones
and that will be particularly magnified
if you do the Delta ring first and they
said well have you any idea what the
skew is between you know he said about
55 to 45
sometimes maybe creeping up to 60 or
whatever and I mean they were all good
statisticians you can imagine it wasn't
bombarded with what
well this is all very well bill but as
we all know this could show up and look
plausible but actually fade away if you
yes you're gonna need lots of ciphertext
how much and I think the answer when you
do the analysis is to be pretty sure
that this isn't a freak result that
you're getting this ratio of loop
whatever it's showing up has 54 to 46
you need about 2,300 characters to be
sure so you do need long messages but if
you get one that is sufficiently long
what it will then ensure for you is that
at the right setting relatively it will
show the 55/45 split if you presume the
wrong setting then randomness takes over
it will be closer to 5050 and then to 55
45 or 60 40 or whatever but in order to
make sure that that distinction between
nearly 50/50 and nearly 55 is really
showing up correctly the Bletchley Park
rule was don't rely on anything less
than 2,000 characters long to show this
up but if it does show up then it is
odds on correct that that is the
relative positioning of those two but
just imagine you've got if you take will
one will - and the Chi set 41 times 31
1271 relative positions and for each one
of those relative positions you got to
squirt through at least 2,000 characters
of ciphertext several million dots and
crosses to be analyzed for even warmer
setting of the winds now you realize why
mechanization was absolutely essential
to first our founding wheel settings
correctly so you know Newman was
delighted because he more or less said
this just proves what I've been saying
we must mechanize everything we can
electromechanical Heath Robinson and of
course later on this really made a huge
difference that chewing through three
million possibilities for every pair of
streams would be pretty slow on an
electric and mechanical machine but it
would be a heck of a lot faster and of
course that is where it ties into
Colossus Colossus could port these
patents to be searched for on a plug
board at the back and basically just
look for them the thing the thing that
Chuck then asked himself is well it's
all about doing these deltas but suppose
just suppose that the Germans really get
their Chi wheel patterns so good that
actually stream one looks like 5050
stream two looks like 5050 they might be
able to disguise each individual stream
quite well but would our think about it
though they're not independent because
of the fact that we get five dots a huge
amount of time in a delta stream occur
at all time every time there's a double
letter what it means is that the dot dot
combination between one and two will be
more common than doc cross cross dot or
even cross cross it should be the most
common one of the four and they won't be
able to disguise that because you know
there is a correlation between these
things and is particularly so that five
dots would be an incredibly uncommon
thing to occur by chance but he's
actually occurring a heck of a lot
because of the nature of exclusive-or so
if we do this delta e on whatever the
germans might be fiendishly clever
enough on any one stream to be able to
hide it but the chances that have been
able to do it across pairs
it's not gonna so basically what you're
looking for in stream 1 on stream 2
together is the occurrence of dot two
dots really it ought to be 25% but it
won't be it'll be
55 over 45 times more common than 25% so
it's these little things you can search
for and if you think you've got
something looking good after 2300
carries a cipher text you then say right
let's correlate stream 2 with stream 3
and then we can find the relative
settings of 2 to 3 & 3 to 4 so after
only five runs on preferably held by
Colossus about 12 minutes per run that
or you could ZZZ through all of these
millions of combinations per relative
setting and say that's in the start
setting some of the Chi wheels are as
follows of course that's only the start
of the process so you've got the Chi
part of the encryption by their laws of
richness of all if you add that back in
to the side for stream what will be left
over is the Sai wheel contribution now
as we found in the early days the silo
settings were dreadful and tended to
just let things repeat over and over
again
well again the Germans have learned from
a lot of experience oh and by the way of
course the number of teeth on the
sidewalls was known so actually as a by
hand method to follow on from the
decaying which Colossus will do then in
the first instance a lot of hand effort
might go into getting the Sai
contribution taken away and revealing
the absolute classic plaintext now
what's going to happen if you think
about him is that by the time you look
at the side contribution you might see
little bits of plaintext showing through
so you need a German expert again and
you need lots and lots and lots and by
hand efforts to say what must the Sai
wheel settings have been which when put
correctly will
this to look like plaintext if the first
set of wheels was taken away the carry
contribution decaying what you're now
doing is D sighing but of course if it
doesn't work it's called deep sighing
thank you yes but very largely it was
possible to make that final adjustment
and get it all backed out and sorted and
showing up very clearly but this really
highlights again how immensely lucky the
Allies were that the wheel patents
didn't change very often so by lots of
hard effort aided by Colossus we managed
to discover the star settings even
without the indicator but you'll have
got the impression very clear there's
still a lot of by hand work had to be
done to get the full story to appear and
this gave rise to the well-known
Bletchley phrase which staggered me one
of her so I couldn't understand it he
said it just to remember Colossus time
is far more valuable than computer time
in those days a computer was a person a
person who did computation so the
computer time was the by hand effort
needed to tidy up the story and you you
didn't worry that there was hours and
hours and hours of that because the will
patterns only changed every month why it
was vital to use Colossus like finding
the star settings was that that changed
every single message so there we go then
that Colossus time is invaluable for
finally the start settings of the wheels
and is far more precious to you than
mere human computer time it wasn't
believed me until the 50s and 60s that
the use of computer as a person began to
fade away even in the late fifties in
the space program people using
electronic mechanical calculators were
called computers you had to carefully
say no no I mean an electronic computer
I mean a digital computer it wasn't till
the sixties that computer without any
prefix came to me
a piece of electronic machinery and I
should caveat this by saying I'm going
we're talking in general terms each
operating system with us Windows Linux
Mac OS iOS BSD insert your favorite
operating system here that you probably